le plus vieux thannois ne s'attendait
pas à ça après le chip le choc de la
cicciolina une robe de paillettes peu de
paillettes parce que peu de robes une
véritable révolution de palais à l'air
et croupe généreusement offerte à la
foule à chint pioline la star du porno
élu député radical n'est vraiment pas
farouche avec des admirateurs on vient
en full tâter le député le plus sexy du
pays
un exhibitionniste dans tout cas qui
fait le bonheur n'est mal italien qui
n'en reviennent pas la cicciolina le
spectacle la mise en scène elle connaît
on l'attendait nu pour cette rentrée
parlementaire
déjouant tous les pronostics la nouvelle
élue du parti radical est arrivé
strictement vêtu accompagné de quelques
stars du porno comme pour bien montrer
qu'elle ne renoncerait pas à sa
profession l'italie toute entière en a
honte mais dans la rue on ne parle que
d'elle pour la retrouver
pendant la guerre du golfe avec une
offre généreuse la cicciolina se porte
volontaire pour faire l'amour avec
saddam hussein en échange de la paix
aujourd'hui la reine du porno stif sa
révérence consciente de la gêne que
représente sa présence
cachez ce sein que je ne saurais voir
c'est en gros ce que le prêtre avait dû
dire pour accepter de mariée hier à
budapest la sulfureuse kitsch lynn et
comme nous sommes à la fois romantique
et cinéphiles
nous avons gardé le baiser pour la fin
[Musique]